next on public lives kevin meny on the
Maverick and his machine Thomas Watson
senior and the making of IBM this talk
is an hour 20 minutes um we're extremely
thrilled to have today's speaker
Kevin Manny and primarily I guess I
should cut I'll go backwards and in the
way he gave me his bio and cut right to
the chase which is that he has his BA in
English and journalism right here from
Rutgers University and from that right
right from skills from this department
and and furthermore I understand was an
editor at the targum when he was here so
for those of you I see that we have we
have a number of students with like
undergraduates I'm really thrilled about
to have young people here and those of
you who may be affiliated with the
targum can take some hope in that that
there may be something there now
interesting Lee he had he tells me his
his technical exposure as an
undergraduate was to have a roommate who
was an engineer nevertheless jobs and
serendipity being what they are
he began his career by working for six
months as a technical writer for General
Electric before he got his first job in
what we would truly consider journalism
though I don't know technical writing is
maybe maybe a form of journalism he
originally joined the Binghamton evening
press as a business writer and then
ended up at the Gannett own Westchester
Rockland newspaper in White Plains as a
business and Technology oh this is
interesting notice how all of a sudden
its business and then it's business and
technology because if you read The Times
or any paper of record right technology
and business are today considered
inseparable and may not always have been
that way but that's part of what the
story that work there we're going to
hear about in in 1985 he went to USA
Today as a technology writer and he's
been an editor of various sorts they are
from 99 1992 and since 1993 has
concentrated strictly on technology
coverage he began writing a weekly
business column in 1991 and focusing on
technology business and technology in
1994 now what brings him to us today is
the site's is widely acclaimed book in
1995 mega media shakeout
he has just published
a book the Maverick and his machine
Thomas Watson senior and the making of
IBM and it's that book from that book
that we're gonna hear about today but
just for those who wandered in off the
street and aren't sure what room you're
in the title of his talk is quite
interesting Watson is a very important
figure to those of us who those was
naturally history center because of his
connection to computer and electrical
engineering this connection to the I
Triple E and but out of this whole
wonderful and there's a copy here which
no doubt will be shown later now this
whole wonderful biography since we have
a more limited time Kevin has chosen to
speak on quote lessons from the Bill
Gates of the 30s how Thomas Watson built
IBM invented the celebrity CEO created
an enduring culture and this is the part
that I knew nothing about and still
found time to take women's shoe shopping
so without further ado mr. meanie it's
the first one of these it's a lot of
pressure I don't know all right
1943 Tom Watson gets up in front of
about 500 IBM errs in Endicott New York
now by this point in time Tom Watson's
senior is a superstar of American
business and even society he's built
this company called IBM that has really
taken off and he's become a friend of
presidents from Franklin Roosevelt and
Herbert Hoover and all these others he's
been in the headlines he's quoted more
than just about any businessman he truly
is basically by this point the Bill
Gates of his time so he gets up in front
of about 500 IBM errs to give a talk and
and in the front row here are his wife
Jeanette sitting here and there is a
this other guy who actually runs some of
the programs at Endicott and next to him
is this up-and-coming young vice
president of IBM and now Watson he was
he could be a good speaker at times but
he often times I mean this was quite an
egotist and he could go on and on and
and it just bramble and he often spoke
extemporaneously in and this particular
instance he's really kind of a dragging
her down and dragging it on and down
there in the front row Jeanette his wife
starts fishing around in her purse and
she pulls out a pen and she pulls out a
little piece of paper and she starts
scribbling on it and she folds it up and
she turns hands it to the young
up-and-coming little vice-president and
says put this on the podium this guy
looks at her with some horror in his
eyes thinking there's what's my career
gonna be after I put this on the podium
and so he kind of said you know what
kind and she just says put around the
podium so he takes the piece of paper
and he figures maybe better actually see
what's in the piece of paper so he
unfolds it and he looks at it and it
says shut up so now he's really in a
panic and he folds it back up but he
hands it back to Jeanette Watts and he
says I can't do this I can't do this
and she looks at him with like bullets
in her eyes and says put it on the
podium and so this guy kind of you know
takes the piece of paper and he sneaks
up on the stage and kind of goes over
very carefully
puts it up on the podium where Watson
speaking so Watson's up here and he's
talking and he's going on away and piece
of paper arrives on the podium and he
picks it up you know sort of without
even looking down picks it but this
piece of paper unfolds it looks at it
doesn't even finish the sentence he says
thank you very much great puts it down
walks off the stage so this is the kind
of little story that helps to humanize
somebody like Tom Watson see it brings
him right down to earth a little about
this the story of getting to the point
of this book and why I told you that
particular story so I grew up in
Binghamton New York and Binghamton New
York is a little town in upstate New
York right next to Endicott New York and
Endicott is where IBM actually grew up
and where it was a sort of heart and
soul of IBM for most of us
distance so I grew up kind of knowing
about Tom Watson this character and this
legendary company and I mean there's a
Watson Boulevard in town you know so you
know who this guy was and you know I
mean there had never been any real great
biographies of this guy to read or
anything like that so I didn't really
know a lot about him just kind of do
basically who he was and so I go along
and I ended up coming here to Rutgers to
go to school and I majored in journalism
in and majored in English I did a lot of
things here belonged to one of the
fraternities that has since been kicked
off the campus but I told one of the
broug here earlier today so which one of
many was that so I guess there's a long
list I don't know and I played played
goalie for the club hockey team while I
was here
met my wife who was also a journalism
student in fact she ended up going into
television and became pretty successful
I mean emmy-winning TV producer and well
I was here started working for the
targum and wrote for the target for a
couple of years became editorial page
editor and it had this very popular
actually you know pretty popular column
on campus and you know you have to
forgive me I will tell you it was
actually called meny yak y8k I haven't
lived that down you know but people who
still know me from those days that let
me forget that and so I you know
graduated from here I went back to
Binghamton my hometown no journalism
jobs available at the time took this
technical writing job got a little bit
interested in that and the but I I
wanted to go work for the newspaper
there and finally get this call from the
editor of the paper who says what we
have we have two openings and we like to
offer you one of them and you can choose
so he said you know one of the openings
was for to be the night cops reporter
and the other was to be a business
reporter now I had no business
experience I know technology experience
or whatsoever but I said I'll be the
business reporter thank you very much
I think the night cops reporter involves
seeing a lot of blood which I really
didn't want to do and so I this is how I
jumped into business reporting and if
you're a business reporter in Binghamton
the main thing you're gonna cover is IBM
because that's the big business in town
which is what led me into covering
things about technology and business you
know in the combination of the two and I
ended up writing about IBM on and off
over the next you know 20 years and so I
you know I I had some sort of interest
in this company and interest in these
characters and a few in about 2000 or so
I was I was casting around for some book
ideas and and had actually told my agent
about this particular book idea and she
really liked it and said that I should
pursue this and I said that well there
was one big thing that I would I would
need to be able to pursue this project
and that would be that I want to go to
IBM and I'd want to find out if there
were some personal papers that would
really make this thing come alive and so
I went to IBM and I said told him what I
was thinking of and and asked him this
question and they said funny you should
ask that because IBM have literally just
realized that in this old warehouse in
Kingston New York there were 340 boxes
of Watson's papers most of which had
dust on him and hadn't been touched in
like 30 years IBM didn't even really
know all of what was in them and the
company ended up I mean took a whole lot
of wrangling and a whole lot of pushing
and and and a person inside who was kind
of a steamroller for me but eventually
IBM said yes you know you can have
access to these to these boxes and in
there was just this amazing just this
amazing treasure of stuff I mean the
kind of thing that you just you know
dream about coming across um there were
of course things like correspondence and
letters and all those kinds of things
between him and employees and him and
his family and there were lists of of
you know the yachts that he owned and
there were there were you know letters
about the his dogs and
you know I mean everything you can
imagine the reason I at different times
I would run across a folder that would
say contents of Tom Watson's pocket he
would actually a few times apparently
emptied his pockets into some real
folder and they stuck it in a file
somewhere hey I have I photocopied a few
say I mean you can't see this but I'll
tell you what's on here I mean but but
literally this was in a folder that said
Tom Watson's pockets and here is you
know a call of somebody wrote about
think magazine which was the same house
magazine that IBM had he actually you
know IBM was famous for this these think
signs many of you might be aware and and
Watson actually had a really good sense
of humor about that he kind of liked
that they were part of the popular you
know culture at the time and so here's
actually like a New Yorker cartoon of a
woman standing in a bathroom and there
are two towels when one says his and the
other says think he thought it was funny
enough to have in his pockets and and
you know and a little a little newspaper
notice about the birth of a daughter of
a friend and here on the bottom is he
used to keep his schedule his daily
schedule IBM made punch card machines
through all this time and information
was kept on a punch card right one of
these old things don't bend fold or
mutilate these hints to have some of you
remember that you know and and so he and
actually as the culture evolved
everybody at IBM would have their
secretaries type their daily schedule on
the back of one of these things because
it fit very nicely in a shirt pocket and
this was you know here's his daily
schedule from that particular day typed
on his punch card
the most valuable thing the thing that I
loved the most let me take a sip excuse
me one second
where there were hundreds of
word-for-word notes from business
meetings I mean this was incredible
who's the actual conversations people
had in important business meetings
verbatim you know right there I mean
some of these were like you know hundred
page long documents it was everything
from the jokes people made when they
came into the room to the stuff they
said when they were all saying goodbye
to each other and there was screaming
and there was yelling and there was
people being cut to ribbons and there
were you know lecturers and there was
everything else you could imagine and
and just and this was the best thing of
all allowed me to actually recreate
conversations and recreate what was
happening inside of these companies and
some of it was just downright fun so I
actually went to pull I'm going to read
the short part from from the book that
is actually taken from that to give you
an idea of what this was like now this
is a meeting around 1940 and IBM Watson
is called into a conference room I
what's this the number of it's 13 ok
calls into a conference room the 13 top
executives of IBM so there you've got 13
highly paid very important people all
assembled in this room including Watson
himself in fact actually the setting is
there the 13 people are all in there
Watson's not arrived yet when this
particular thing starts so here's what
happens so Watson pushes into the room
and the first thing he says is don't
bother to stand up Watson said
apparently in an impatient mood takes up
too much time and it breaks your trend
of thought I don't like it slam and
three sentences Watson pinned those 13
executives and establish total control
over the room now what's the news Watson
said briskly opening this high-level
meeting we're aiming to win that speed
contest said one of the men they were
there to discuss of all things a typing
competition didn't these guys know world
war was brewing aiming to were going to
win it when is it at Watson said the
19th two weeks from now came the reply
we're planning to have a full force out
there ahead of time to handle the
publicity both we and the Home Office
here now we've worked up some newspaper
advertisements to follow it we have two
or three alternatives miss ham amay wynn
and set a new record Mizpah Judas may
win and set a new record one may win and
not set a new record so we have to be
quite varied here with the planning if
everything should go wrong watson said
if someone outside should win then we
won't come back we'll just keep
traveling what executives said everybody
laughed and it actually in the text it's
little parentheses that everybody
laughed so we know why everybody laugh
the competition was the annual
international commercial schools typing
contest an obscure event that IBM was
about to overrun and inflate in a move
as ill proportioned as the New York
Yankees showing up to compete in a
little league baseball game IBM made
typewriters among the first electric
typewriters and Watson wanted to be able
to advertise that his company's
typewriters worked the fastest to prove
it IBM needed to find a legitimate third
party typing contest dramatically play
up the event to national ads and make
sure the winner typed on IBM typewriters
IBM found the fastest typists in the
world and hired them just to
competitively type the company's hopes
rested with Miss Margaret Hamma
and Stella páginas it also hired a 1909
world champion typist a male to coach
Hema and for juna's the coach drilled
the women all day every day honing their
skills so it would not be possible for
them to lose ever you talk to miss
hammer what senesce the group she feels
that she's all tuned up miss Hammond
believes she's going to win we're not so
sure we have another contestant to junus
who's also good as she ever sat at a
speed contest with Miss Hammer Watson
said yes they're training together and
they were training in a building on
Fifth Avenue blocks from IBM have they
trained in front of a group
no it's been secret
competitiveness sidled through sizzle
through Watson and it could excite every
molecule in his body until he almost
vibrated from it the typing contest
would give IBM and advertising edge a
legitimate reason to say it had the
fastest typewriters beyond that Watson
wanted to win there was Watson the
famous businessman the friend of
presidents the international lobbyist
for peace for peace through Commerce
devoting a large chunk of his time at
the time of 13 well-paid and busy
subordinates to ensuring victory in the
international commercial schools typing
contest would it be too much trouble
we'll go down there Watson said
excitedly he wanted to rip up his
schedule for the day so he could get
closer to the action let's go down do
you think there will be a new record and
executive said that's the ideal thing if
there can be a new record we don't need
to think Watson said we could find out
these girls can write so many words per
minute I would like to go down there and
sit there while they do in the end
Watson got his victory Hamill won
banging out a hundred and forty nine
words per minute
it was indeed a world record five years
later for Judas typing for IBM beat
hammers record hitting two hundred and
sixteen words per minute anybody was a
typist here you know as of this writing
and as of this moment the Genesis record
stands unbroken
there's a meeting inside of IBM through
the Watson era so I had I had I had
access to this kind of material and
really for the first time anybody
outside of IBM had ever looked at this
than anybody in decades had looked at
this stuff and it was in and having this
and having the other kinds of things
that I was able to get access to enabled
me to do something with this book that I
really wanted to do which was I wanted
to write a bi biography I wanted to
write a history that was that read like
a novel that was as good as the best
fiction that you could read and there
were there were three slick three things
that I really wanted to accomplish you
know one was that I really wanted to
develop this
character this this amazing
larger-than-life character with all the
other depth that you'd find in you know
in a novel I also wanted to make sure
readers could understand what really
happened how he accomplished these
amazing things that he accomplished you
know basically end up having you feel
like you took the journey with him and
and finally you know I I really hope to
try to find some of those some of those
universal truths about what Watson was
about and what he went through things
that people can relate to today but more
importantly that lessons people can take
away both in business and in technology
and for that matter you know in any and
any part of life they might take away
from this so those those are the things
that I set out to do so what kind of
character you know if I tried to bring
this character out what are some of the
things about this character of Tom
Watson senior so Tom Watson senior he
was probably about you know just to give
you a physical idea he's probably about
two inches taller than me about six to
tall guy tall lanky guy had this very
crumbly sort of voice often cleared his
throat when he spoke so doesn't feel I
had there were also many many films of
him speaking that I ended up having a
chance to go through drive you nuts
because you'd be watching these films
and you'd be speaking any of you saying
well now here I mean we're going to
after about a hundred hours of those
tapes he was a man who had this
explosive temper which was probably his
single worst trait there was this great
series of notes for meetings in 1916 and
Tom Watson senior had actually he was 40
years old when he took over this company
in 1914 called the computer tabulating
recording company he did not start IBM I
there was this little conglomerate that
had been kind of puttering along for a
number of years and not doing
that well that he took charge of in 1914
so two years later here's Watson and he
comes in in the morning and he calls all
of his sales executives into a meeting
and he calls him and he starts yelling
at him because that because he's looking
at this sales report and there's all of
these dates on here that say that a
particular company took in an IBM
machine on say you know nine three you
would say yeah or how would this work we
say like Oh we'd say like 4:15 you know
4/15 and returned it on 9/15 or
something like that well Watson you know
solid these figures and and thought that
it looked like that all of these
machines were going into companies and
they were returning them and saying you
know we don't want them you know six
months later nine months later and this
kind of that kind of you know turnover
that kind of machine's going in and
coming out and whatever was really bad
for IBM his business they would lose
money on those kinds of things and so he
calls a salesman and he starts screaming
at them you know you didn't tell me
anything about these they're this fast
turnover that's happening and and you
know don't you read these reports and
you know and he's laying into him and he
goes on and nobody challenges him in the
room everybody stays quiet for the whole
time and finally he dismisses them they
go away and the next thing I find in the
in the papers is another meeting about
three hours later calls all the same
people back into the room and he
realizes that he had read all of the
dates wrong nine fifteen didn't mean
September fifty that meant September
1915 and you know eight then two eight
six you know so he was reading what he
was thinking was just a couple of months
apart were actually like you know a year
or three years or something like that
apart and so he calls up a salesman back
in and instead of apologizing and saying
I'm sorry ever the dates wrong you know
four he gives them all a ton of crap for
not challenged
in the first place and telling him that
the dates were wrong so he starts going
you know don't you ever challenge me you
know to read these and he goes on and he
rips him apart again and then he throws
him out of the media again so this was a
man this was very difficult to work for
our dives he was a man of this this a
great deal of explosive temper he was
not a technical person he grew up on a
farm up in upstate New York he he did
was not one of these guys who tinkered
in the backyard with machines or had any
education and technology or anything
like that he didn't didn't know those
things he was a very charismatic kind of
personality so people you know he could
talk to people people liked him people
bought things for a movie be him a very
good salesman he had a he had a way of
thinking that ended up helping him a
great deal in later years which we could
he could absorb a great deal of
information and then see it simply and
and spit it back at people in very
simple terms this was probably one of
his greatest skills and when it came to
running this very complex organization
building complex products he could soak
in tons of information and then just see
the simplest straight line about what
was what this was about and just tell
people that in it and you know give them
something very simple that they could
follow and what ended up one of the
things that ended up one of the traits
that ended up happening was it even
though he didn't know technology and he
couldn't put a computer together to save
his life or anything like that he could
sell computers like nobody ever before
or you know in some case it's the
summary since ever since one of his like
a particular stroke of genius was when
IBM built its first full-scale actual
electronic computer this thing called
the SSE C and at that particular time
computers were something that you know
that nobody ever people didn't see they
didn't have a concept they didn't have a
tangible idea of what a computer was so
Watson says let's take this thing that
we've just built this experimental lab
thing and put it in the lobby of our
building in
on Madison Avenue New York so he puts
this computer in the lobby and opens the
lobby to the public and he puts it so
you know the big plate-glass windows so
people could see it from you know from
all sides and it becomes a tourist
attraction The New Yorker writes a story
about it
I mean people actually you know started
to love this thing that you know they
would they would get given they would
they would come up with names for it
and this was the first real
popularization of the computer that that
happened and it was because of the way
that this guy thought he was masterfully
manipulative and he was manipulative by
doing this this good cop bad cop thing
where he would be incredibly generous
with praise and with rewards on one hand
and and then rip somebody apart on the
other hand throwing them like so
completely off balance that they just
craved this guy's this guy's attention
this guy's approval because they knew
the approval meant you know such
wonderful rewards and and disapproval
meant such you know terrible lashings
there was a particular person who put
this he had a personal story about this
there weren't a lot of people know Tom
Watson died in 1956 or there weren't a
lot of people around the interview or
actually knew the guy but there was one
man named Jim Birkenstock and Jim
Birkenstock is 90 some years old now he
lives down in Florida he was a young
hotshot executive at IBM when he was in
his 30s in the night beginning in the
late 1930s worked side by side with
Watson for a couple of decades and so
he's he's the living person who saw and
knew the most about him of anybody out
there so I went down to his home and
interviewed him for I mean he was
wonderfully generous we talked for hours
and hours about about Watson and heard
all of his stories but and this one sort
of yin-yang thing he illustrates this
early and Birkenstocks career before he
went to headquarters and became a an
executive he was when he was a new hire
he was this Salesman you know just like
some assistant salesman in Kansas City
nobody means so far away from Watson's
universe that
Watson wouldn't have any idea who this
guy was and he and his wife had a
one-year-old son and they're driving
through Illinois I believe they have a
terrible auto accident his son his
one-year-old son was killed he and his
wife both wound up with serious injuries
and in the hospital now there is no
health insurance at this particular time
corporate America you know so he hears
Birkenstock and you know obviously gone
through this horrible horrible thing and
also facing the financial burden of
dealing with it after that and the next
thing he knows is a local IBM
representative shows up at his bedside
with a letter from Watson personal
letter from Watson and a check for
$5,000 and he basically says I heard
about your accident you know I'm so very
sorry and here's this is to cover any
medical expenses and funeral expenses
for your son and anything else did you
know again not anybody he knew from Adam
and his Birkenstock put it he said that
man at that moment one my loyalty for
life well another incident later in his
career a little flipside of that
so Birkenstock at this point in time is
a top level executive and he's in a
meeting and Watson has this impossible
project that he once done and this
project has an impossible deadline and
he turns to Birkenstock and he says I
want you to take it on well
Birkenstocks says it's an impossible
project with an impossible deadline you
know I can't do it and Watson who knows
blows up and he says all right if you
can't do it then I'm gonna give it to
you know like Schmitt over here and I'm
gonna help him personally so Birkenstock
says okay okay okay fine he goes back to
his office within 30 minutes
one of Watson's secretary shows up at
Birkenstocks desk and he said go on home
you're going on vacation
I've vergis eyes like what's going on
the Secretary says there's a car
for you downstairs gonna take you home
you're going so he goes first he's like
what's going on he goes downstairs he
gets in the car car takes him back to
his house his wife had already been
called and told the pack they put him in
the car and this guy drives him out to a
resort in the Pocono Mountains on the
rainiest week in a cold you know late
fall day when it's there's nobody there
and it's absolutely miserable so what
furgus taught you to realize is
essentially what Watson has done to him
first of all put him on some kind of
like house arrest basically and the
message that vergis thought got loud and
clear was you my friend are dispensable
I can do without you for a week
and if you you know you want to cross me
again you know this is what's gonna
happen and basically he was forced to
stay at this lousy resort for you know a
week and the right so this was this was
a way that Watson could be very
manipulative especially to the people
who were closest to him the shoes the
women's shoes
since it's in the title I have to tell
you about it there was another person
who knew Watson pretty well um there was
this woman named Eleanor Ervin who I
found in Delhi New York and Eleanor was
a young woman who joined in the mid
1930s IBM had a program one of the first
management training programs in
corporate America for women it's called
a system service school and Endicott and
Eleanor Ervin was one of the early
graduates or attendees to this system
service school and and she the the
Watsons basically befriended her and she
spent a lot of time with them and and it
would you know do some you know do some
activities with them or help them out in
different ways different times they like
they like basically kind of keeping her
around to having her around to do stuff
for them and so she had a lot of little
stories about Watson and once she was
telling about you know would he hear
these little stories
it's really interesting because he's
kind of start to realize that you know
that Watson had this this interesting
sort of little feminine side to him
and so she tells us one story about how
he and he he had four or five young
women from the system service school and
he had it in his mind that on this
particular day in New York he was going
to take them with him on his meetings to
Wall Street into some other places so
that they could sort of get an idea of
you know big corporate America because
so it turns out that it's this rainy
horrible miserable day in Manhattan and
he's you know dragging them all over the
New York and you know their shoes get
ruined and so they fight at the end of
the day the car drives back to IBM's
headquarters in Madison Avenue and they
all pile out of the car and the women
think well we're just going you know
over here into IBM's headquarters and
they all got out of the car Watson says
nope follow me and he brings him over
across the street next door I guess it
was next door to a shoe store and takes
him in and says you know it says all
right you know every one of you can pick
out you know whatever pair of shoes you
want and and as Eleanor was saying that
he got the biggest kick out he would he
actually got totally involved in what
all the women were picking out you know
telling him what one's oh that looks oh
how about this / for you and he's like
is it and she said he that she never saw
him have you know a better time than
that he had helping five women pick out
shoes was always it this was the this
was that side of Watson so all in all
you know he was he certainly was mean by
by the nineteen by the 1930s 1940s
timeframe this guy is you know he is he
is the Bill Gates of his time I mean
here's a guy who's quirky personalities
built this company that that is just you
know taking off it gets lots of press
coverage he was in the 1930s the US
government started keeping track of the
salaries of top executives we after
didn't as the New Deal rule then this
was something that Congress started
doing and the first list came out in
1935
and the highest paid the highest paid
person in America was Tom Watson senior
that particular year in the middle of
the depression and he became famous
because it was that year here in the
middle of the worst you know depression
he made three hundred and sixty-five
thousand dollars and so the press
immediately dubbed in the thousand
dollar a day man and this kind of stuck
with him for a while so he was you know
he was he was wealthy he was famous he
was he was everywhere and he was just he
essentially became the first real
celebrity CEO at that particular and he
used this celebrity to try to promote
IBM to tell people about his company
that made all these you know machines
that essentially operated in the back
rooms of businesses yeah that's
something most people would touch or use
not like Microsoft Windows or we all
have to you know use it every day so
what's my time here so how how how did
he do it the how did he do a part of
this well you know can't get into all
the details of you know in this kind of
a setting but one of the things that was
fun to find in researching this and
looking at the story was that Watson
this guy who looks like this you know
this guy who looks like you know this
old banker running a company that we all
think of as kind of stiff and you know
sour in some ways this guy turns out to
be this this real seat-of-the-pants you
know nut case when it comes to making
business decisions he's willing to take
these huge huge Gamble's time and time
again and and his luck is incredible I
mean essentially he ends up making all
of these huge Gamble's at exactly the
right time usually for all of the wrong
reasons and there's one one of the
stories like that has to do with the way
IBM got into electronics so IBM had been
from its beginning until World War two
had been this company that made
mechanical electromechanical punch card
machines kept track of information on
those little cards they worked by you
with these mechanical
relays and electricity it was just it
was these you know sort of old-style
clanky noisy machines that work very
slowly and as world war ii is ending
this there starts to be a lot of
research in in and around the idea of
electronics of vacuum tubes being able
to do this job much much faster than an
electromechanical machine could do and
and at first Watson and pretty much most
other businessman in the area in this
this field really don't see much of a
use for this technology they basically
think that it's probably something
that's very far off and maybe can do
stuff for scientific calculations but
who needs this stuff for business you
know doesn't make any sense who want to
make calculations that fast you don't
need that and so Watson tears of this
researcher named Howard Aiken an hour
taken is this brash young guy at Harvard
University whose proposed to Harvard to
make the world's biggest information
processing machine and essentially he's
really talking about sort of doing some
tricky software programming I mean that
will essentially do some some using some
tricky stuff does lash together a whole
bunch of IBM machines and make a giant
data processing machine but he gets his
proposal to Harvard and and Harvard
turns him down a couple of times and you
know says you know we're really not not
interested we don't see it used for this
at this particular time Watson has it in
his head that he wants to forge a
relationship with Harvard and he hears
about Aiken and he sees an opportunity
season-opening you figures well you know
what I could fund this Howard Aiken guy
and fund his computer and we would get
some you know researching some public
relations benefits out of you know out
of doing this and we create a
relationship with Harvard and then when
it's all done we can just we can
dissemble it from from IBM and Endicott
and put it into Harvard and donate it to
them and say ok you know now this is
Harvard's machine you guys can do
research on it or with it or whatever
you want to do
so he's got this whole plan this whole
idea of pap tapped out and the public at
this point it's times are starting to
get interested in these kinds of things
these thinking machines and he realizes
he's going to get a big PR boost out of
it at the end when they unveil this
thing so he goes okay we're gonna do
this so he finds Howard Aiken and they
can spends about two years in IBM's
buildings in Endicott New York building
this contraption this thing they spent
another year or so hey you know haggling
over patent rights and all this other
kind of stuff and finally finally this
thing is ready and it gets taken apart
put on some trucks shipped up to Harvard
and Watson is anticipating this huge big
event go up to Harvard and they're going
to you know have a big public relations
announcement and press from around the
world blow the top off of this thing
make headlines so Watson gets on a train
so thing is scheduled for a Monday it's
a Sunday hops on a train to go from New
York up to Boston he arrives in Boston
as rainy horrible day and a
representative from IBM picks him up in
his little Chevy and takes him out to
his car Watson hops in the front seat
and Genet's with him she climbed into
the back and the guy sits in the
driver's seat and he hands Watson that
day's newspaper the Sunday newspaper
from Boston and there on the front page
as this big headline the sentence says
Harvard builds thinking machine on
Sunday this is supposed to come out on
Monday and Watson starts looking at the
story and it goes on and on about
Harvard and doesn't mention IBM anywhere
in the story so Watson starts getting
mad and he starts you know asking this
asking his poor driver who you know if
this is in you know all the newspapers
and the guy says yeah it's and all the
Boston newspapers today you know it's
it's just everywhere Watson's like just
blowing up and guy goes back to his
hotel and he calls in the Harvard's Dean
and he calls an ache and he screams out
of and yells out oven tells him you know
I care about IBM the way you guys care
what are you guys doing well it turns
out that Aiken had taken it upon himself
to send the proud
a press release a day early claiming all
of the credit for this particular
machine Li said of course is just beside
himself and he you know he decides to go
through with the ceremony is planned on
Monday and they go through all this and
he gets on the train at the end of it
goes back to New York goes into his
office first thing he does is he calls
in his two top research and development
people and as soon as their Fannie's hit
the cherry says build me a sheen that
machine that makes that guy look
ridiculous
IBM got into electronics as an act of
vengeance and it turned out okay right
madhu right move wrong reasons that's an
example so anyway I the the this guy
didn't always do things right he
certainly made his mistakes and among
those mistakes the biggest mistake of
his life
most newest most notorious mistake of
his life was his involvement with Nazi
Germany which got a lot of play in
publicity a year or two ago when a book
came out just you know describing some
of this and actually was you know kind
of a extreme view I think of what had
gone on at least you know in the
research that I did but here's you know
maybe here's a brief story of what
happened so it's the 1930s the Nazis are
coming to power and Watson is coming to
power at the same time essentially you
know and Watson starts getting it in his
head that he wants to be something more
than just the IBM guy he wants to have
some kind of like you know what he
starts admiring Franklin Roosevelt he
wants to be like Franklin Roosevelt he
wants to be this world leader this guy
who influences history and so he but he
wants to do it through business he wants
to do it somehow through you know while
still being this the head of IBM and so
he ends up running for the presidency of
an organization
call the International Chamber of
Commerce and he becomes president and to
be honest actually in 1936 1937 nobody
else wanted to be President of the
International Chamber of Commerce
because of all of the political
ramifications of the things that were
going on in the world at that particular
time it was like a powder keg so Watson
said I'll be President he just comes
president of the ICC and in 1937
so the Olympics in Berlin are 1936 this
is a year when people start really
getting this taste of Hitler and his
master race thing and the Nazis are
starting to really look like you know
start start to look like bad people but
the whole idea of what you know they're
about in the in the you know certainly
their attitude towards Jews and all this
has not yet really come out in the world
press so 1937 the International Chamber
of Commerce is going to have its World
Congress in Berlin so there's about
20,000 people from all over the world
representatives from business and from
governments and things like that they're
all coming into this World Congress in
Berlin in 1937 and the Nazis are very
conscious of they want to put on this
big show they want to show the world
that they are legitimate they want to
show the world that they want to play
you know the world commerce game they
don't want to be cut off so they want to
put on a big show so the Watson and the
all these other thousands of people come
into Berlin and the Nazis put on this
huge party and they put on events of you
know big things of concert halls and all
these kinds of things are going on and
as the at one point Watson gets a
meeting with Hitler and he goes into the
meeting now Watson's mindset is here's
Watson's mindset goes ne stays I am the
world's greatest salesman I mean by this
time he believes I'm the world's
greatest salesman and he's got this
slogan that he's cooked up called world
peace through World Trade it's got an
advertising slogan for this idea
and he thinks I'm gonna go in I'm gonna
sell Hitler on the idea that peace and
Commerce is better than war so it goes
into this meeting as tea with Hitler and
you know there's about five or six other
people around the table and what's said
in this meeting is not recorded know
where I could find out what everybody
came away with but Watson comes out of
the meeting and he stands in front of a
banker reporters from around the world
and he says Hitler promises there's no
war Hitler says no no country can afford
war at least of all Germany you know
international commerce is the way to go
everything's cool and the papers around
the world print this and the next the
next day there is the sort of
penultimate event the big you know final
thing and what's happening at this
particular event is the outgoing
president is essentially handing off the
presidency to the incoming president and
as part of this the Nazi economic
minister gets up in front of everybody
gives us nice florid speech about all
that the International Chamber of
Commerce has done for World the world
and for Germany and all the stuff and he
calls up the outgoing president and he
calls up Watson and he gives both of
them a Nazi medal now the medal is this
second highest medal that the Nazis can
give to a foreigner now just to put it
in a little bit of perspective American
businesses businessmen didn't think that
was all that bad America I mean at that
particular moment in time there was a
senior vice president of General Motors
who got the highest medal the Nazis
could give Henry Ford known anti-semite
that he was he actually got the highest
medal that the Nazis could award so you
know this is not like out of hugely out
of context that he gets something like
this but nonetheless
he accepts this this prestigious medal
from the Nazis and and he he goes home
and within a year or so this starts to
become you know become a real
millstone around his neck and he and
there starts to be some you know some
rumors that IBM machines are being used
to help you know run censuses that could
help find us or help keep track of Jews
in concentration camps as is that kind
of stuff starts to come you know to come
out when in actuality you know the idea
that IBM was actually building machines
for those purposes is kind of nuts
because essentially Germany had access
to all those machines I mean it had a
factory there was a factory inside of
Germany that was making those machines
before the war they had all of these and
every time the Nazi army would go
overrun another European city the army
would go pack up all the IBM machines
and send them back to Berlin anyway so
they could do they had lots of them they
did what they want with him but
nonetheless it starts looking worse and
worse for Watson as the you know years
ago on in 1939 2:30 1940 rolls around
obviously things bad things are
happening in Germany war is brewing
finally in June of 1940 Watson packs up
the medal and sends it back to Hitler
with a note saying you know here take
this back please and and in fact oddly
enough what this ends up being seen as
sort of a heroic act at that particular
time you look at the newspaper and
magazines accounts of the moment and and
Americans end up cheering this as this
sort of slap in the face to Hitler and
in fact Hitler and the Germans are mad
as bees and and you know just threatened
to cut off IBM and tell Boston you could
never again show his face in Germany
which you know actually we know who won
that side of that and so so this ends up
becoming oddly enough ends up becoming a
non-issue after that for IBM which is
interesting because you know in fact
there was a there was a something I
thought was very telling was I found
there was a Saturday Evening Post story
from 1943 about Watson a profile of
Watson it's a 12 page magazine story
it's huge story it's 12 page magazine
story about Watson you know basically in
those times when all
these things are happening and the first
mention of anything about the metal or
about the Nazis occurs on page 11 so
when you're in the context of those
particular times it actually didn't seem
like that big a deal now we stand back
here in this particular point time in
history you look back and you say oh my
god you know those were bad people how
could you do I could even you know do
anything with em how could you take
their medal are you but how could you
let them use these machines for these
things and it's you know a legitimate
thing to think from our particular
perspective in time but you have to put
yourself in that particular time when it
looked very different at that for them
just to conclude so we didn't I'm gon
burning kind of long here but I'll just
end with saying that Watson finally died
in 1956 he ran IBM up until one month
before he died and it was he was 82
years old and one of the things that I
it had have to tell you about this was
this weird reaction to him just
something that happened
I'd been researching Boston going
through all these papers and you know
getting to know this know this guy and
one of the things I thought one of the
last things I ended up ended up finding
was of his desk calendars actually had
his desk calendars from 1940 to 1956 I
could see every meeting he was in and
everything did it was really pretty you
know pretty fabulous and so I'm going
along going through them you know one
year at a time looking through stuff and
I get to 1956 which is you know the
Europeans are dying and I'm going
through and I get to May 22nd 1956 and I
realized after that there's nothing this
is the last day here's this calendar
from the last day that Tom Watson
stepped foot in IBM and I mean here you
be you know this guy at this point is
actually becoming pretty ill with ulcers
with some other problems so it comes in
he comes in at 10:42 and from 1042 to
49 he meets with somebody named
hutchinson I don't know watch as it is
from 10 49 to 11:05 he meets with his
son Tom Watson jr. who ends up taking
the company over from Watson after he
leaves from 11:05 to 11 26 for those 21
minutes in his office are Dominick the
barber and a manicurist from eleven
twenty seven to eleven thirty six a guy
named Kristensen was in his office I
don't know who that is eleven thirty
eight to twelve eighteen he walks over
to the st. Regis Hotel near IBM's
headquarters for a meeting of the IBM
Board of Directors and a lunch in his
honor then there's an entry that says
twelve eighteen to one ten it just says
ante room down there which actually
meant he took a nap
the antsy room is a little room off his
office where he had a couch
would you like to stretch out on your
knees he got older one 10:00 to 2:00
p.m. went back over to the st. Regis for
another event in his honor and at 3:30
p.m. that afternoon he went home for the
last time and it was really kind of
interesting you know I mean after all
that time and and all that time spent
with this guy and you come to this last
page and it was like oh my god you know
it's like it almost felt like seeing the
guy die in front of you or something it
was very interesting reaction I felt at
that particular moment sitting there in
this windowless room at IBM looking for
this stuff and you know so that's I mean
Watson ended up being you know this is
this major character in American history
and I wanted to read to you this very
pressing and interesting little
paragraph from the San Francisco
Chronicle which ran the day after he
died
and it was his obituary or editorial
about about his death and particularly
because the San Francisco Chronicle of
course at the time in 1956 was not the
center of the technology universe but
certainly would become that so The
Chronicle wrote about Watson he will be
remembered by posterity we think not for
his ability to sell but for having made
possible the age of automation into
which the world seems now to be entering
denizens of that brave and accurate and
button-pushing age will doubtless revere
Thomas J Watson precisely as inhabitants
of the present automotive age Revere
Henry Ford and so that's what I found
about this man thank you very much so
I'm sorry for being long-winded but we
can do we can do it yes so we can do
questions if anybody still wants to be
here yeah so I have to ask you to come
to the mic and and please tell me who
you are so we can have that Michael Lusk
a lot of the other leaders you've
compared him to the Fords and Carnegie's
and Fricks have big mansions and museums
that they clearly spent their money on
offhand I can't think of any associated
with Watson
did he not collect a lot of personal
money or did he spend it on something I
don't know about or what right I mean no
the Gates has a house that's in the
newspapers yeah I know it's a good
question it actually goes back to to how
Watson structured his company he never
built the kind of wealth that those
great industrialists built because of
the way that he structured his situation
at the company so Watson he had had this
to this career at national cash register
before coming to IBM and got fired from
NCR and ended up looking for a job and
there was this guy named Charles Flint
who had this little conglomerate that he
put together called the computer
tabulating recording company CTR and
they built scales for butcher shops and
they built these time punch machines for
factories and they and they actually had
this little division that was the
smallest of the bunch which was the
tabulating Machine Company which was
Herman Hollerith companies the
you invented the tabulating machine
which ended up becoming you know the
core of IBM's business all those years
later but so Flint hires Watson to take
on this this company that is essentially
falling apart and so Watson is not the
founder he doesn't have he never
actually in the entire time he worked
there he never had more than 3% of the
stock of the company and in the
beginning it was more like 1% that he
was given as he started and and he
structured his contract so that he got a
cut of profits which I mean is pretty
much unheard of today but this is why he
was the highest-paid CEO in the 1930s
because IBM was a profitable company in
those years despite the depression and
so Watson was getting this huge amount
of cash in salary but he didn't have a
great deal of you know of stock that
built into this great you know huge
amount of wealth like the Carnegie's or
the JP Morgan's or Bill Gates today or
you know any of these kinds of people so
you know he never had that kind of great
wealth to end up you know funding a a
you know a great foundation or a
university or any of these other things
and there is not today you know any any
major thing with the watson name on it
there's no huge Batson mansion like the
Hearst Castle or anything like that and
and in fact the the watson wealth is
very dissipated at this particular time
despite the fact that IBM through all
those years that he was there and then
through the Tom Watson junior years was
created as much wealth as any industrial
company in the history of America but it
didn't go to the Watson's yes
right thanks John the eye I saw remember
Tom Watson Jr's autobiography being
described by one reviewer at least in
the first 50 or 60 pages that are where
he deals with Tom Watson senior reviewer
described it as all about how horrible
it was to be Tom Watson juniors son or
time wants to seen your son I mean
that's especially the way that this
whole you know tone of that first part
of his autobiography was was terrible
was to be this man's son and and and Tom
Watson senior really had I mean he
really had blind spots first I mean that
to him is Tom Watson jr. was you know
despite the fact that Tom Watson jr. was
you know got horrible marks in school
and was a you know essentially a
troublemaker through college and you
know he's gonna be this young man who
was gonna make nothing of himself I mean
Tom Watson his father Tom Watson senior
always always thought this guy you know
the son was gonna take over the business
he wanted to hand off his business to
his son and the relationship after Tom
Watson jr. joined the company was
incredibly rocky and full of fireworks
and they fought over everything and to
the point when there's there's
incidences when with the that end with
Tom Watson jr. you know this grown man
literally fleeing from his father's
office in in falling on some other
executives couch and crying I mean you
know it's like these these kinds of
scenes inside of inside of IBM and and
not until not until Tom Watson's senior
ended up essentially handing over the
company day-to-day operations to Tom
Watson jr. did that relationship start
to smooth out and they stopped fighting
over power and over everything else but
Tom Watson just as a difference between
these two guys Tom Watson senior was one
of the great company builders in
American history great entrepreneur
absolutely horrible big company manager
I mean this this guy wanted to have all
control basically come through him
funnel through him is his Organization
for the company was more like a spider
and web kind of thing with here's the
spider and you know everything else is
sort of built around him which as IBM
got bigger and bigger bigger just didn't
work it was just to unwieldly one man
couldn't be at the center of all that
and Tom Watson jr. ended up turning out
to turn out to be one of the greatest
chief executives of American history a
very different thing than being one of
the great company builders
I don't think Tom Watson jr. could have
built a company from scratch but he
ended up being an excellent person at
organizing a giant corporation and and
he you know the first thing he did after
his father's death was essentially take
down a whole crew of his executives down
in Williamsburg Virginia and create a
new company structure that was based on
more of a hierarchy with different
people running different divisions and
something that's more familiar to us
today so he he certainly went in a
different direction than his father head
Gus Friedrich guy you started by reading
a transcript of a meeting I'm wondering
if you learned how those transcripts got
created and whether they were used in
any fashion at the time shortly
thereafter yeah that's a good question
because who would be crazy enough to do
this right one of the things that uh
that the Tom Watson senior believed from
the day he walked in to run this company
was that he was going to build a great
company now if CTR was falling apart at
this time so he walks in the door and he
starts telling all these people you know
we're gonna build this worldwide
institution this great company and
they're all looking at him like he's a
maniac because they're thinking well
we're not gonna have jobs tomorrow this
company's going out of business and he
preached this and preached this and
preached this from the day that he
walked in that we're building and we're
here to build a great company we're here
to build something bigger than what we
are and and that was his I mean that was
his focus
his entire career was it was not about
we're gonna build the next best computer
overnight we're gonna create some great
advertising campaign everything that he
did was all centered around the idea
that we're going to build a great
company a great institution first
whatever else spun out of that and in
whatever we created was because we are
the great company a great institution
well go because he went into it with
that mindset from day one he believed
that what he was doing was going to be
great and if he was going to be great
then it better be preserved for
posterity so he began from the beginning
having stenographers come into meetings
and at first taking notes and actually
later in life he would have those you
know court reporters or the little
machines in every important business
meeting taking these things down there
are there there are hundreds of hours of
of film that was taken of events at idea
of Watson doing things there are
countless thousands of photographs
throughout the entire period of time
that we're talking about I mean he this
man saved everything and he saved it
from early on completely believing that
posterity was going to want it which is
I mean an act of egotism beyond belief
when you think about it but you know and
on the other hand think thankfully he
did and yeah yeah he did it out got a
complete ego basically yes okay you're
gonna have to go
my name is Mike Trout I'm a information
technology student here I heard a story
a while ago that IBM was floundering
around the time that the computers were
just starting to develop and they were
saved by a massive government contract I
think from what was it the Census Bureau
or at the IRS and I don't remember the
details of that story but wondering if
you could talk about that but Watson's
role was during that time yeah got some
time frames a little shifted but will it
what this is again falls under the under
the under the heading of right I'm sorry
right i it's the sense well it's well
this actually I think what we're
referring to is during the New Deal and
in the 1930s and this falls under the
category of you know right decision for
the wrong reasons at the wrong at the
right time you know and luck playing a
big role so IBM had been in the 1920s
IBM was what you describe today is like
a hot tech growth company you know it's
booming it's zooming it's growing by
huge amounts every year 1929 comes you
know October 1929 stock market crashes
the economy goes through the floor and
just about every company out there
starts to cut back and you know lay off
people cut research and development do
you know trust just try to survive I
mean the impact is huge and it's an
almost immediate so Watson makes a
couple of really interesting decisions
key decisions at this time first of all
he is he completely believes that the
depression is only gonna last a very
short period of time or this this
unfortunate economic situation is going
to only last for a short period of time
and and that at the end of that time IBM
demand for IBM's machines is gonna pop
because anybody who was putting off
purchase of these things was just gonna
you know got a watermain so he makes one
decision that first of all I'm not going
to lay off a single person or close any
actors instead I'm just gonna keep
building machines and building parts no
matter what happens keep these people
employed I don't want it you know I've
spent so much time and effort and
everything you know training these
people and building these factories the
last thing I want to do is cut them out
so he starts just saying okay I'll just
you know build parts and stick them in a
warehouse if I have to and wait for the
day when the demand pops and you know
I'll have these things ready to go
so first decision not going to layoff
anybody keep the factories running put
the stuff in warehouses second decision
is instead of cutting research and
development which everybody else was
doing he decides to increase the
spending on R&D and in fact in 1933
decides to build a standalone research
lab in Endicott and and he's essentially
spending six percent of the company's
revenues for that year to build this
thing in the worst of the depression and
he starts poaching researchers from
other companies that are laying them off
and you know basically you know trying
to trying to build up the the company's
products and get ahead of everybody else
well so this is fine
through 1933 1934 rolls around the
depression isn't going away
IBM is spending all this money to you
know run these factories to store these
parts you know to you know do this
research and development and it's
basically bleeding cash and it starts to
get worse and worse and late 1934 rolls
around and basically the company the
Board of Directors meets and discusses
throwing Watson out because the
company's getting so close to insolvency
and so eats his way through that gets
into the 1935 and in 1935 Franklin
Roosevelt signs into law the Social
Security Act well basically there never
has never probably in the history of man
been a single bigger information problem
created with one stroke of a pen is the
Social Security Act all of a sudden you
know with this one particular thing
every company has to keep track of you
know payroll keep track of its employees
send this information to the federal
government which then has to process all
this information is sent
checks back outs everybody and nobody
had expected it to be the kind of
serious information problem that it
ended up being companies that had IBM
machines needed more of them and
government needed rooms and rooms full
of them and by that point in time by
1935 every competitor had either just
you know shrunk to almost nothing or
gone out of business and they had old
products because they weren't spending
it on R&D and also in Watson just its
able to turn around and say wow you need
machines
I got machines I got a whole warehouse
full of them over here
and look they happen to have all these
new fancy gadgets on them that we've
been cooking up in our R&D labs and
basically there is nowhere else to turn
and IBM gets this gigantic federal
government contract for the to process
everything for the New Deal and it ends
up getting you know contracts from every
company out there and this becomes this
becomes IBM slingshot it's essentially
from this point in time for the next 40
plus years that IBM completely and
totally dominates the information
processing industry and it really all
all generated from the seed of that
particular set of decisions and and that
pop that it got in 1935 so I think
that's where you were referring to but
we had one did you have something I
guess my question
I'm Lisa Coby I'm from skells and you
said at the beginning of your talk that
you were looking when you were starting
the project for some universal
platitudes so I was wondering if you
could comment on what what kinds of
lessons watts Watson senior has for the
current Silicon Valley executives and
maybe even think about would would a
what a Thomas Watson survive is is there
you know aspects of him that it would be
successful in today's world yeah thanks
yeah no actually there is one of the one
of the things that I've taken away
actually I should I should turn that
around and put it this way I have I by
now had a chance to talk with a lot of
chief executives of companies big and
small who have
who have read the book and so let me
sort of digest the things because I end
up hearing from them what they take away
from it and and I think that's where you
where some of this lies the first of
those is the power of corporate culture
watson was the first chief executive to
really understand what a corporate
culture was to really feed it grow it
and and understand that that that could
be the source the center of power for a
company and and and just how important
it is to the creation of a great company
one of the things that when Lou Gerstner
came in and took charge of IBM when it
was it was you know kind of sinking in
the nineteen 1990s he came in not
thinking that particular that corporate
culture was particularly an important
thing and over the next 10 years of
running IBM one of the things that he
came away from was under saying he
discovered at IBM that that culture is
not just part of the game for a great
company it is the game it to use his
words and and that's something that
seems to be lost on increasing numbers
of CEOs today and especially like in a
place like Silicon Valley which you
brought up in Silicon Valley companies
tend to start up and adopt the culture
of Silicon Valley you know this this
very broad idea of of you know people
show up for work and they're you know
shorts and Birkenstocks and you know
that we all have you know beer bashes on
Thursday and we you know and we're all
you know the whole thing of what Silicon
Valley companies are about and companies
tend to start up in Silicon Valley and
adopt that culture instead of having its
own distinct culture and in part there's
a reason for that because the people
then can be very mobile right you know
you lose your job in one Silicon Valley
company and you can plug into another
one without any hesitation whatsoever
because they're all of the same culture
but on the other hand they're missing
this this one thing that can define and
and help a great company succeed of
having its own very distinctive culture
so that was that was something that
that definitely has come through I mean
another another one is that you know
just the longevity of the story
we're talking about a guy takes charge
of a company in 1914 and lets go of it
in 1956 and and through that time never
really loses focus of what he's about
and what the company's about what he's
trying to do and you know I think that
that has definitely had an impact on the
kind of corporate managers that we have
you know today that basically are trying
to manage to get the stock price to meet
some analyst estimate for the next
quarter so I I think that that's
something that that I've heard a lot of
spit back at me and and one of the other
things that that that I think in this
particular point in time this this time
of Enron and world comm and all these
other things was that Watson Watson
built this company on sort of you know
your basic of you know American
church-going values and he was a
stickler for that you know IBM was going
to be some I mean if it's gonna be this
great institution who's gonna be this
worldwide institution was gonna stand
for something and was going to stand for
something good and you know I mean he
could still be a tough hard-as-nails
competitor they still did some things
that were maybe questionable but
nonetheless I mean overall this company
was basically going to you know was was
built on values and everybody understood
what they were and everybody better stay
in line or they were gonna get dejected
from that culture and and I guess a lot
of people have said to me it's nice to
know nice to read that story and know
that you don't have to be Enron you
don't have to be Wellcome to be
successful you know in business you can
be you can be a company that's built on
values like that so I think those are
the three things that I've heard the
most yes okay yes we have
since 50 years ago IBM has always been
known for its scientific research and
technological development now my
question is although you mentioned the
Harvard case my question is that how R&D
came to IBM and IBM and like through
what process were brought and through
what process IBM took the lead in this
industry
okay thank you okay brief story they
will quit up Tom Watson senior was
starter his career his basically the
major part of his career at national
cash register and he ended up becoming
going up to become sales manager of the
National Cash Register and so well he's
at NCR and he's trying to figure out how
to sell more cash registers he ends up
becoming friends with a researcher that
the company had hired named Charles
Kettering now Charles Kettering actually
ended up becoming one of the great
industrial researchers of at history
ended up going on to be to be at General
Motors and becoming GM's and you know
you've heard of the Sloan Kettering
foundation I mean that's that's the
Kettering he basically you know created
cars for General Motors for several
decades but at this particular time
Kettering is this new young guy
researcher at NCR and Watson is the
salesman very technical and unscientific
Kettering is this very sort of over
educated or bane technical wizard and
the two become close friends and
Kettering starts to show Watson how
invention can drive sales and the first
time that this really like sort of Sears
into his mind is at this in about 1907
NCR is making cash registers at all all
mechanical so there's to get the drawer
to come out you're basically turning
this crank on the side and there's a
little mechanical contraption role as a
drawer out so Kettering and Watson get
together and they talk about well what
if we had an electric
or a little electric gadget so when you
push the button for the sail it rolled
the drawer out now this is going to do
absolutely nothing for the productivity
of anybody working in you owning a cash
register I mean all it does is it rolls
the drawer out for you but at this
particular time electricity is something
new and cool and having a an electric
drawer that would roll out which just
seemed like the greatest little belt
land whistle going so the big problem is
is that there's no electric motor that
could do something like this it could
provide this little burst of energy to
roll a drawer out and kettering sets out
to try to figure out how to do this so
we come back at one point he comes back
with with this little model that he
built and he says I think I've got it
you know tells Watson I think I've got
this this little work and Watson's you
know she shows him and it works in
everything watch this says well you know
but one problem is a lot of our cash
registers are used you know in places
like maybe you know a fish market or
something a place where there's gonna be
a lot of moisture what you know will
work if there's a lot of moisture if the
thing is gonna go getting wet so
Kettering says well I don't know so he
walks out of the room he comes back with
a pail of water and he puts it on the
floor he says let's find out
flop traps his motor in the water he
says we'll try it tomorrow they go away
they leave this thing soaking in the
bucket of water overnight this is one
model that he's made and come back to
the next boring they take it out and
they plug it in and sure enough the
thing works and so they they hey Watson
is very impressed by Kettering and he's
very impressed by this you know his his
you know sort of confidence in them and
all this and he puts it in the cash
registers and these things fire off the
shelf you know it becomes a big seller
and and boom I mean it's just Watson
just sort of this it hits him that that
you know new gadgets new new you know
technology can actually drive the sales
of you know of a product like that and
it really is from this this and Watson
Kettering stay lifelong friends and he
often turns to him for advice and in
fact Watson goes to IBM or goes to CTR
starts this company
starts running this company one of the
first thing he does is he gets alone to
hire a group of Corps in you know
engineers his first you know hires and
he specifically at Togo's to the guy
he's going to do this and describes
Charles Kettering and says I want a lab
full of Charles Kettering's so hired me
people that are like him and and it
really is from this Corps I mean from
this moment that that Watson has a
complete dedication to research and
development and and you there is no
point when he deviates from that from
that point on he's constantly building
his his R&D organization he's you know
builds this lab in the middle of the
depression he continually hires more
people and adding them out and and it's
just I mean it's just something that
he's devoted to and it it really all
goes back to one friendship in 1907 with
Charles Kettering so thank you very much
everyone for coming
Kevin mania is a nationally syndicated
technology columnist for USA Today the
Maverick and his machine is published by
Wiley on the web at wily dot-com next
week on public lives midge